well I was present in court in relation  to another matter but I can report is  that the Chief Justice was told with  shown documents to the effect that the  Chief Minister had given notice of the  ship is no longer specified within the  provisions of the sanctions there is no  cause for its arrest and therefore it  has already been released from the to  stay within the media office which is  just around the corner there and I  suggest you should go there immediately  go ms child's go basically it has just  mean  the order for its arrest has been  revoked it's no longer valid or extent  so it will leave today releases  immediate why are you a lawyer  yes I'm a barrister lomas same in  context to your gear  that's elapsed now for you to go because  there is no order requiring it to stay  to extradite to the US it's not going to  exit